President Joe Biden and Republican house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy have reached an
agreement to raise the debt ceiling we
still have a lot of work to do but I
believe this is an agreement in
principle that's worthy of the American
people the agreement still needs to be
approved by Congress before June 5th
when the government could run short of
money to pay its debts and fund
government programs
David Harrison covers the U.S economy
and the Federal Reserve for the journal
he explains what's in the deal and
whether Democrats or Republicans if
anyone came out ahead the two big parts
of this deal first of all obviously is
that it raises the debt ceiling for a
couple years basically pushes it off to
after the election
the Republicans really got an agreement
to curb spending uh for next year and to
cap it for the subsequent year this is
the deal is good news I believe you'll
see every American people
the agreement prevents the worst
possible crisis on default for the first
time in our nation's history there are a
lot of other smaller things there's new
requirements that people on food stamps
either are employed or are enrolled in
some kind of program and some some
Provisions to streamline or make it
easier to get energy projects approved
President Biden has delivered a result
that avoids a catastrophic default that
prevents us from our economy crashing
Democrats got suspending cuts that were
not nearly as deep as the Republicans
had initially put forward now comes the
next phase which is the democracy has to
sell this deal to his members to The
House Republicans we did a conference
call with our conference in over 95
percent were overwhelmingly excited
about what they see a number of the more
conservative members of the House of GOP
caucus have come out in opposition to it
calling it a disaster or something
calling it appalling basically saying
that McCarthy gave up too much Democrats
to raise the debt ceiling likewise on
the Democratic side some of the sort of
more Progressive Democrats are very
concerned about things like the work
requirements for for uh Aid programs
some of the spending cuts terrible
policy absolutely terrible policy does
not reduce spending actually by some
estimates creates a burden on
administrative spending that is actually
worse for you know for overall cost of a
program like that the spell is going to
have a rough ride on Capitol Hill we've
already heard from some folks on the
right on the left who oppose it and so
now the question is whether there'll be
enough in the middle to to carry it
through we know at any time when you sit
and negotiate within two parties that
you got to work with both sides of the
aisle so it's not a hundred percent of
what everybody wants but when you look
the country is going to be stronger we
have a June 5th deadline to raise the
debt ceiling according to the treasury
Department if Congress does not raise
the ceiling by then a government could
quite literally run out of money to pay
its bills I strongly urge both both
champ to pass that agreement let's keep
moving forward on meeting our
obligations and building the strongest
economy in the history of the world
foreign